[Música]
olá meu nome é max tem 10 anos e hoje eu
vou mostrar pra vocês um tema que eu
gosto muito e que eu acho muito
importante respeitar os animais
agora vamos ter uma foto pra você e se
provê o que vocês acham bonitinho né
até acho bonitinho mas será que esses
pobres animais estão achando graça nisso
nós humanos temos certa tendência de
tratar os animais como brinquedos mas a
gente tem que pensar que os animais
também têm sentimentos e podem ser
sentimento até mais fiéis de que os
nossos dados em divulgado pelo ibge é
revelam que o cachorro é de fato o
melhor amigo do homem e da mulher em
44,3 por cento dos domicílios
brasileiros apenas um cachorro quando o
chamado de 52,2 milhões de cães
já a população de gatos foi avaliado em
cerca de 22 milhões
acabamos de ver existem mais cachorros e
gatos do que crianças nas nossas
propriedades qual é porque ele dar o
tratamento adequado os bichos
cada animal requer o seu próprio cuidado
exemplo o cachorro precisa passear duas
vezes por dia ou o gato precisa de água
corrente na casa e o peixe precisa que a
água do aquário seja trocada
agora vou falar de algum tipo de mal se
aduz que a gente faz que são horríveis
esses pobres cabelos estão trabalhando
horas e horas e horas com essas madeiras
pesadíssimas nas costas e com esses
negócios
boca deles 10 morderem mas pra quê
sendo que esses cabelos são animais
muito lanços
tá bom a gente tem que pode fazer esse
passeio isso só que a gente tem que
respeitar o tempo de trabalho deles e
tirar esse negócio da boca deles mas não
é só ensinar aos tratos tem macaco presa
em cativeiro para experiências vaquejada
farra do boi tinha de gal rodeio e eu
pra circo
esses são os ativistas são pessoas que
gostam de animais igual eu gosto
eles ajudam esses animais eles querem
nos ajudar
eu gosto disso mas eu sou o sócio é só
esse novos atos
agora vou falar de maus tratos de
animais domésticos que se chama o
abandono
a gente pega cachorro e gato e depois de
um tempo a gente jogadores na rua que se
eu acho horrível mas existem 11
institutos que pegam esses animais
cuidam desses animais e depois de outras
pessoas boas
eu fui um instituto chamado instituto
luíz anel trabalho
na verdade desde pequenininha sempre
gostei muito de cachorro e gato e desde
que nem eu sempre gostei muito de
animais abandonados e aí eu comecei a
trabalhar primeiro em um hospital que eu
sempre quis ser veterinária e depois
surgiu a oportunidade de trabalhar com o
cachorro abandonado que eu acho que
gostei
lá eu tinha entrevistado a doutora
marina passadori a gente também pode
ajudar mas sabem como a gente pode pegar
comida e água e dá para esses animais
que estão na rua igual eu fiz
junte se a nós e muito obrigado
[Aplausos]